well aaron judge and the yankees had a
big 10-game road trip where they won
seven games and tonight they'll be
facing the chicago white sox the team
with the best record in the american
league
it's the first of three games here at
the stadium well when you look at
jordan montgomery's line as he toes the
slab and the boogie down he needs to get
a little more consistency going
from start to start his last start out
he gave up two earned runs in five
innings and a couple of four earned runs
a couple of times in a row so you know
he needs to get that consistency in
order to do that get that breaking stuff
going get that curveball going that's so
good
that slider and cutter that gives you
the hard end part that's the part that's
missing his changeup's been good
swung on and popped him up to shallow
right judge coming on coming on makes
the catch
so judge joins a list of about 8 000
others who've made all three outs in the
unit
carlos radon coming off his toughest
start of the year he's on for his
seventh start
five and one a brilliant year 147 era
you look at strikeouts there's a bunch
of them in 36 and two thirds
49 to be exact he's gotten the ball over
the plate 2-2 home
swing and a foul tip strike three when
you set down
d.j lemay via the strikeout
you're working that's a swing and a miss
half swing on the slider and carlos
rodon
has a sword out with two down here in
the first well done
by the way this slider is unhittable
swing and a miss on an inside
slider carlos rodon just struck out the
side
carlos is slicing the strike zone oh two
foul tips strike three
four batters four strikeouts for carlos
he's coming here as they call the big
stage
and he's pretty much walking out there
alone it's a one-man show to this point
fifth straight strikeout for carlos
rodon
carlos rodon is the first pitcher since
sandy koufax
in game one of the 1963 world series to
start a game with five
straight strikeouts against the yankees
in new york this is danny mendick
that one's driven deep to right field
judge on the run on the track he'll make
the play
right in front of the scoreboard he made
the catch and then
plunged into the scoreboard well
at the scoreboard wall is now hurt and
duhar at third gardner at second
pitch to le mayhew brown balls at first
abreu's going to throw home
and gets the out another high awareness
play
by jose abreu at first base to cut down
a run
two outs in the inning they're at the
corners swing and a miss
strike three rodon you could probably
hear him screaming
the yankees leave two the yankees by the
way
at 27 consecutive innings have the
longest scoreless streak in major league
baseball
struck him out swinging high fastball
and that is strikeout number nine for
montgomery carlos rodon
have provided the propulsion for 11
strikeouts
at yankee stadium tonight back to the
rubber scoreless bottom
six one and two on lamehiu who is d.h
tonight that is strike three and a tie
of a career-high for carlos rodon
a dozen strikeouts at yankee stadium
tonight
one out to go here in the sixth inning
but this is the one guy that worries you
and it's
aaron judge swinging a miss 13
strikeouts for rodon
a new career high we've played six
managers don't send guys like ron doll
up there to
work a walk to get to the next guys
putting up there so he can drive in the
run
struck him out swinging slow breaking
ball montgomery
just notched his 11th strikeout so he
pitches a seven inning shutout with 11
strikeouts and is no better than even
michael kopeck coming in behind carlos
rodon's career high
13 strikeouts there's labor torres
swung on hit in the air to deep right
that ball is high not as far
it is gone
it's labor day gleber
torres goes to right field to break up
the two shutouts
and like a good glaber torres is there
he homers to right and the yankees take
a one-nothing lead
well give him a lot of credit delay but
taurus had struck out
twice before finally got that fastball
was
it was elevated boy is he happy this
might be the happiest we've seen him all
year
well there's your four seamer and i tell
you what he stayed on it
he didn't try to pull it he is such a
good hitter when he uses the whole field
and the sox have the tying run 90 feet
away the yankees now have a drawn in
infield against nick madrigal nick
throws the bat at it flares it to right
and it ties the ball game nikki two
strikes
just flung his baseball bat at the
oncoming ball and we're tied at one
that's unreal a little half cut
floater dying quail
whatever you want to call it hawk called
it a duck snort
they're all right and they just tied the
game
nick madrigal comes through it's one to
one and that run
takes kopeck off the hook line to right
field coming on his judge he's gonna
play it on a hop
fires to second gets the force
[Applause]
madrigal had to wait to see if judge was
going to catch it
when he didn't judge
kind of deke madrigal and he then got it
on one up and
fired to second and he really was out so
it's a force play
so moncada is safe on the field his
choice
here is le mayhew first and third no on
out pitch
on the ground to second tim holm
and the tag there he's out of the
baseline
and the out made at the plate so tim
comes home
and gets wade one gone lemay hughes out
avoid the batter liner caught by
montcotta the third baseman he'll throw
to second they double off
gardner and the inning is over
are you kidding me it is a miracle
at yankee stadium so first and second no
one out so here is andrew vaughn
grounded to third there's one there's
two
there it is it's a triple play
they got a triple play to get out of the
jam
a shella to adore devoid
five four three triple play
well what a ball game this is the ball
game has everything
so the yankees have two on and no one
out here's labor torres he's been the
offense for the yankees
it's sharply a basement to left field
judge rounds third
they're waving them home here's the
throw here's the play
yankees win 2-1 that's about as good a
ball game as you'll ever see
where everything happens when they're
off to a great start here
in a big series against the white sox